Oh my god, Tom Hiddleston dropping all the
bombs.
So he basically confirmed that hell is going
to be death in the marble cinematic universe
like the Thanos is cosmic that.
So I'm going to explain what's going on but
he also teased Doctor strange as well.
There is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway
going on.
All you have to do to enters be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'll announce
the winners at the end be sure to click that
bell to enable alerts so you don't miss anything.
So this is huge.
Tom Hiddleston was actually at the Golden
globes excepting for the night manager which
is a drama series with you Lori was like a
completely separate thing, but he just confirm
Hela will be the marble cinematic universe
version of death which made a may be surprised.
Maybe not be a surprise, just because they
tend to simplify things like they have Kate
freaking Blanchette one of the best living
actresses right now playing one of the biggest
most powerful characters in the marble cinematic
universe.
It makes sense that they would try to find
another way to incorporate her into other
big storylines like Avengers infinity war
in Thanos, so top 10 things about this number
10.
This is all based on Jack Kirby's Ragnarok
storyline, which was like the last couple
issues of Thor that he wrote for marvel before
he went to DC and did new gods stuff.
If you want to read those issues.
It starts with Thor number 175 and go through
177, so it's like the last three issues that
Jack Kirby's ever wrote on the original Thor
comic book number nine.
She's just as powerful as normal as guardians,
but in the comics this is a little bit different.
She has a pact with the cosmic entity death
which in the comics is like a separate thing
that allows her to collect a portion of the
souls of dead as guardians and bring them
to her realm.
So she is kind of like a smaller version of
the devil for Asgard that she in her own right,
shares a lot of the same physiology as normal
as guardian.
So she does have magical abilities she curses
Thor with immortality.
She's able to restore people to live she has
certain magical abilities that go beyond what
you would think the Doctor strange or low-key
would be able to do so she's on par with the
big magical beings of the Marvel universe.
She is the daughter of Loki, but not the current
version of the character she's the daughter
of a Loki from a previous version of Ragnarok
so Ragnarok is the cycle of death and rebirth
where the gods die new gods are born in their
place.
Some are resurrected, so she's the daughter
of a previous version of Loki, but Odin is
the one who appoints her goddess of the realm
of death.
So it's sort of like exile you can see how
Hela might be a little bit bitter about that.
So they might incorporate that into the movie
as well like she's been banished for all of
these years from Asgard.
Even though she is the daughter of an as guardian
number eight.
During that original Ragnarok storyline while
Loki is taking over Asgard Hela steals a portion
of Odin soul like as if you were in the Odin
sleep steals a portion of his soul and creates
a being called infinity with it now Marvel
is that like a couple different versions of
infinity in the comics, but number seven this
version of infinity had a child known as eon
which was responsible for protecting the Celeste
Teal axis which is like the life force that
flowed through the world tree which is kind
of like the way the as guardians used to describe
the universe number six hell is main weapon
is the night sword.
It's a magical sword that is on par with a
lot of other as guardian weapons.
It's not quite as powerful is Thor's hammer,
which itself is actually a living entity.
I'll explain how Thor's hammer is really alive
there's like a consciousness of the hammer
and it doesn't really speak that often that
hell is night sword is one of the most powerful
weapons next to Odin spear, which is technically
the most powerful and Thor's hammer is always
a lot of arguments about who has the most
powerful weapon, technically you would say
Thor's hammer is the most powerful, but because
Odin has the Odin force and wields it through
the spear the spear becomes the most powerful
weapon, so the most powerful God typically
has the most powerful weapon.
But if Thor is doing his job and the hammers
working the way it's supposed to.
It would be the most powerful weapon, so number
five.
The next most powerful weapon that she actually
gets to use is twilight the sword of fire
Lord searcher who is a big figure in Ragnarok.
So Cerner himself has a long history fighting
against Odin Thor has to battle him back into
submission, but he's so powerful that he has
to use several different artifacts to do it
and it had a lot of battles during the comics
but the Odin force in itself was created when
Odin first trapped fire Lord searcher in his
realm, which is down here in the world tree,
so the way you view this is the way the as
guardians view the universe itself.
So you have hell is realm down here nipple
Chaim right under mid guard which is no sort
of like the mortal plane in Asgard up here
at the top of the technically Walhalla is
the as guardian version of heaven.
It does exist in Marvel comics, but the way
you see like the balance here is that Odin
is God, he protects the nine realms their
version of the devil is Hela she presides
over the realm of death Alexa portion of the
souls.
So even though Hela resides over the realm
of death number four fire Lord starter very
important in the takeover of Asgard.
So Loki is planing to take control of Asgard
makes a pact with Hela, but separately also
releases fire Lord starter from his realm,
so that he can run amok and go crazy Hela
didn't wield his sword till much later in
the comics but you can see how they all work
together to create this chaos where Loki was
trying to take over Asgard, but Hela has her
own plans, which provides for number three
the opportunity for Loki to not be the villain
of the story.
He was the villain of sorts for the first
two movies much less so during Thor the dark
world.
Still, very bad, but he really just wants
to rule.
So when he makes his Faustian bargains as
he tends to do she storms Asgard forcing the
Loki to make a bargain with Thor, to try and
fix everything so that he gets to be the hero
of his own story even though he created this
problem in the first place.
Number two this provides the entry point for
Doctor strange so that he can help Loki and
Thor locate Odin restore his soul that has
been stolen from him so that he can regain
the Odin force and fight off Hela in the minions
of Ragnarok Thorne holds very important of
this equation.
But because this video is a little bit more
about Hela we talk about number one Thanos
in his relationship with death and how that's
going to change in the marble cinematic universe,
because it seems like the Marvel movies are
now combining the cosmic entity death with
the as guardian version of death in Hela with
Cate Blanchett and Thanos will try to make
a pact with her because she wants to destroy
the universe Thanos in the comics is in love
with death.
So it's a very meta-concept being in love
with the idea of death, but because marble
has like a physical cosmic entity death you
can reach out and touch he literally loves
her wants to make her his bride, but hilariously
she rejects them and it leads to his ultimate
undoing now infinity war.
The movie isn't going to be exactly like the
infinity, comic book storyline, but until
Thanos assembles all of the infinity gems
and wears the gauntlet Cate Blanchett's character
Hela will be the most powerful villain inside
this marvel universe, not including Dormammu
will become a much bigger thing later in Marvel
phase 4.
So that's getting a little ahead of the story
so we can talk about it down the road.
Congratulations to the latest Spider-Man giveaway
winner Maiden X you win a $20 comixology giftcard
be sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your contact
details.
There is a new round that started in this
video.
If you want to request a special Marvel movie
video or something related just leave it in
the comments while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn all about
the planet Hulk storyline that's going to
be happening during Ragnarok and you can click
here for my Justice league Preview of all
the costumes.
Thank you so much for watching I'll see you
guys next video!